sports stats okay let's go through some
of those okay
you got
tiger's dad okay
you got
uh lavar ball you got uh uh the
manning's father who's got two bars two
archie man who's got two boys with two
super bowls each which is insane right
yep you got king richard you got
emmanuel agassi you got a lot of these
stories right mj's dad mj's dad yeah but
you know okay fine you can put mj's dad
there as well all these stories with
these dads so then the question becomes
the final one you know how when i talk
to investors i say what's most important
the entrepreneur the talent and the
entrepreneurs uh team the idea the
technology what's most important right
or you'll ask
hey uh tom uh pan who was a gm for the
philadelphia 76 i think he was gm and
then he went to espn so what's most
important the ownership team a great
coach a superstar player or a great gm
right you ask these questions okay
in these specific examples williams okay
agassi
you know manning's all this stuff
who
gets the bigger percentage of success
okay and i know that's the last thing
you want to be pressured to talk about
because i think it's what percentage is
parents
what percentage is kids
no it's it's to me the biggest
percentage is always the parents you got
to remember this is your degree by the
way how big of a percentage by the way
it could be well over 75
this is the genetics listen the genetics
i'll say it again
i've never had anybody come to me and
the the parent did nothing and the other
parent did nothing and the kid became a
world-class athlete
i've just never seen it in my sport
there's some can you repeat that folks
if you guys so some people ask me and
they say why do you bring somebody who's
a tennis coach we never talk tennis here
i'm a parent
and i only bring people here to my show
that i'm interested in not you're
interested in this is called the pbd
podcast because i
want to learn on how to become a full
complete package better human being and
a leader okay listen to what he just
said i judge myself kind of like people
ask me oh my god pat you're so impressed
i'm like dude you don't know my dad
you give me way too much credit
my dad raised the damn standards on work
ethic and if you say you're gonna do
something you do it and honesty and all
this stuff i get way too much credit you
should give more credit to my dad eighty
percent of credit should be to my debt
on how he raised me the how he
challenged me how it was never enough it
was so freaking annoying sometimes yeah
right and then you and
obviously dad and mom mom played a
different role role as well
but it's such a important dynamic on
what you just said can you repeat that
sentence one more time you've never seen
a
no i've never seen someone become a
world-class player okay in in my sport
that the mom or dad didn't do something
in sports you know with the genetics
like whether they played high level
college or high school or maybe the
family tree it could be a grandfather
who was an olympic sprinter or you know
a russian who was a a swimmer so there
has to be something i've never seen it
ever okay but you're saying physically
genetics are you also saying how they
know interact with their child
physically now the mental part yeah okay
uh because remember if they're with rick
macey or whoever they're with me x
amount of time a day the rest of the
time when you go home and close that
door you're with family
you don't know what's percolating you
don't know what life lessons are going
into that kid's head how they're how
they're wired you know it's it's it's
major league to me it's the most
important that's why once again you
asked me about american tennis and
listen i'm not throwing a net out there
over the whole country or everybody
you're always going to have those flyers
but at the end of the day the eastern
europeans you got people they're rougher
they're tougher it's like when i saw
serena she was like a little pit bull
once she got a hold of you she wasn't
gonna let go and i just said i gotta get
this kid's strokes in a serve and so
that's that's you know and that's half
the battle how you're going to handle
you know and and
how you're going to compete and you can
teach that and nurture it and i do that
yeah but it's hard to rewire things that
have been put in these kids head so so
you know how uh uh uh
the the story of uh what's that one
movie with russell crowe the beautiful
mind where you're going to that one
place that he has and it's got all these
formulas like what the hell is in this
guy's mind what does he think about it
or even greg kating who found who killed
tupac and big and he's got this whole
report of names there in even the
american gangster where there's this one
scene where it's like who is the drug
dealer behind everything and you know
it's denzel washington
it's
typically when you see like somebody
you know performing at a high level
somebody in that lineage raised the
standards was tough was a son of a [ __ ]
was difficult was challenging nothing
was ever enough and papa like when
agassi tells a story with my dad nothing
was ever enough i don't know if you know
his story is a different story as well
it's almost like yeah buddy but you
would have never married graff if that
wasn't your dad
you would have never met her you would
have never been a champion if
i was i totally get it frustrating
totally get it i get that fully
understand it but they're
it's almost like you know mike mike
talked about in the last dance where he
says when you're going through it
it's so difficult
when my dad was pre this is what michael
says in the last dance do you remember
that once he when he says you know hey
michael why don't you go play outside do
you know what you know yeah you're just
not let me and your brother do what
they're doing he says in that moment it
drove me it was so difficult to go
through it
but he made it through and look what
level of a champion he became
it becomes mentally and emotionally
tough to be able to handle all this
pressure so i don't know i think the
part that you talk about that people are
raising more soft
people today and parents is like oh my
gosh you're okay oh my gosh you okay oh
my gosh you're okay i don't know a lot
of oh my gosh you're okay growing up uh
you know as a kid so listen some people
today will call that terrible parenting
rick how dare you say such a thing
you're not empathetic
you're not compassionate you don't
understand what it is you know so all
this stuff that you talk about but the
the the percentage of making it to the
top level take elon musk's that away
and his dad doesn't say what he says to
him does he almost become who he is
today i don't know about that do you
have another tiger woods ever tiger
woods won the 2007 us open with a broken
knee unbelievable that's a that's a rare
specimen right there with his dad did
you watch his documentary well and yeah
and he said phil mickelson is a better
player than he is right but he didn't
have the worth work ethic that that earl
woods instilled in tiger woods that
killer instinct did you watch the
documentary parts of it have you watched
a documentary like half of it i dude i
highly recommend you watch the whole
thing did you did you get it i did not
i'm telling you guys i so here's the
mistake i made one night i started
watching at 10 30 and it's three hours i
said i'm gonna watch it today and i'm
gonna finish the next three nights i
stay up to two o'clock in the morning i
watch part one and part two it's that
ridiculous that's why i'm a big fan of
tiger i mean even all the stuff that he
has i'm just a fan of tiger i'm a fan of
people that are willing to tolerate that
much pain
it is so difficult to become a williams
yeah it is so difficult to win at that
level well pat let me ask you because
you started the conversation or this
question with you know are kids
conditioned these days or the phobia
these days and and obviously you
transitioned to you wouldn't be who you
were without
your dad zero right and he's a coach god
would have chosen somebody else's my dad
you know you don't know who i am my
question to you is then pat as a father
you told the story a couple podcasts ago
about you went up to i think dylan's
coach and you were like no you could be
hard on him that's fine yeah you know
you told that story yeah
you know but you're seeing what kids are
dealing with these days everything that
rick just said about social media and
you know the phobias how are you taking
this information and becoming a better
dad to your kids in today's generation
so he made a very good point in sales i
made a mistake early on of driving
everybody the same way because i drove
this one guy this one way and it worked
with them i said this is gonna work with
everybody he hated it she couldn't
handle it he quit like what happened how
come you can't be like this person well
they're different personalities can't
drive everybody the same way right one
is more encouragement the other one
needs to say well i think that guys woke
up an hour before you made 100 more
calls than you that worked with him but
it discouraged this one then the other
one was good with the selfish desires he
wants the big house the accolades the
fame all that stuff but this other one
could give a [ __ ] about all that stuff
this one wants to do it for mom and dad
to make them proud that other person
loves america and his country he wants
to do something to give back to the
country that gave him his freedom and
this other guy's from el salvador he
loves his country but he came here he
can't stand the fact that what happened
to el salvador he wants to make money
the one that go back and be in office in
el salvador that person is driven in a
different way so not everybody is driven
the same way so with my kids i asked
them a question earlier about different
ways of coaching like what your kids
need
at the when they're younger it's just
for them to love the game
then the next phase is what your kids
need at this age is more fundamentals
right like learning like you know
perfect practice makes perfect not
practice makes perfect they have to add
the perfect practice makes perfect okay
so now they need to learn the
fundamentals the right way like i'm not
teaching tico i throw the ball i'm the
wrong guy to teach you how to throw the
ball you can teach them how to throw the
ball better than i can teach them how to
throw the ball right because you're an
athlete i was not right so now it's
getting the fundamental people around
them and to also like the game a little
bit of competition a little bit of
pressure then the real pressure's
showing up when you're getting at the 10
to 14 age you kind of seen a little bit
can they handle it or not you need a
little bit more support all this stuff
to watch them i don't know i just
watched to see we're all different
and with the kids yesterday we're
playing baseball outside dylan wants to
go
45 more minutes let me hit five more
balls
let me hit five more balls
let me at five that no no that wasn't
long enough five more i'm like at this
point i'm we missed church we missed
church yesterday because of dylan well
i'm disappointed i'm like five more
balls i know i missed you at the you
would you want you want that passion i
mean that's gold right there you don't
you're not pushing that's from within my
oldest my oldest said daddy i want to go
inside and draw uh more uh movie
characters see you later but the point
is his you later
is hollywood and movies storytelling
it's not baseball so i'm trying to as a
parent like your daughters they don't
want to play tennis but they crush it in
gymnastics
it's that
you not getting in the way of what is
their strength
and yet still having to teach them
mental and emotional toughness no matter
what game they play so my son's like
yeah i don't like baseball why don't you
like baseball he had one very bad moment
in baseball that's private between him
and i
and uh
like so i whispered to him i said come
here is that why and he kind of looks
away so that's why isn't it because at
one moment yeah
so that's between you and i she says but
i don't like baseball i said do you not
like baseball do you not like it because
it links to a painful moment i said what
are you gonna do when you make a movie
one day and everybody says it's a
terrible movie how you gonna handle that
good point what are you gonna you think
this thing is a baseball thing this is a
life thing baby
this is everything we do we do podcasts
it's just the shittiest podcast ever
than the next podcast just the best
podcast ever than the next podcast you
guys suck two podcasts later just the
greatest they're going to be the biggest
like it's such a bipolar thing that
you've got to be able to manage it no
you've got to be able to you got to be
able to say
that parents need to be more more than
anything psychiatrists not coaches right
yeah psychologists they get
psychologists yeah but let me let me
just go back to something you said
earlier about the the coaching parks i
think this is important okay i can have
a kid who's dead tired okay and they
they can't go anymore and i might say
okay we're gonna do
a 20 ball suicide where i just run them
side to side okay and they get to 18 and
they just can't go anymore and all
sudden i say
20 you get this ball and let me tell you
something there's turbo inside the kid
that i've never seen before or if i say
i'll give you a hoodie
like the one i have on or
uh you get a gatorade or i'll give you
five bucks or water capitalism okay
here's what happens when there's grades
or there's rewards i don't care how
tired you are you could be throwing up
okay i always have the quote one more
one more
as in wn okay
and
this is what i do with everybody okay i
get them to push boundaries
challenge their limits not limit their
challenges and so it's amazing the water
ball if i say water bowl okay out of
nowhere
you got like uson bolt you know you just
got this lightning the kids like dragon
whatever because the mind controls the
body okay and you know i talked to him
about navy seals i talked to him about
all these type of things and i give
situations when i say
water ball
all the parents like they just laugh
because 98 of the kids all sudden it's
like
they just run like you have no idea
where before they're letting the mind
control the body or
if i put kids together
and we they could be dead tired and we
play tag
in an area
okay all sudden they're not tired
anymore they're shaking and baking
they're juking they're bobbing they're
weaving they're running all over the
place even though they're dead tired
because of one word
fun when it's fun
okay
you are not tired anymore whether it's
business whether i'm just telling and
this is how it comes across in the movie
so do i do things differently i feel the
temperature okay and i react accordingly
because i keep balls and strikes on
every lessons you got to get better or
you're getting worse if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]